that's been modernized to the current
standard right um okay
by the way let me talk about the look at
those weird bugs there um let me talk
about this the size of those of those
some vertices have you have you gone
through with people what what what is
the algorithm were using for that the
size of the vertex yes we have a a
formula we we did use which is I think
proportional to the position of the
vertex in the unit box so are you happy
with what it does um yes it were quick
from small to large one okay fine all
right good okay okay
I'm really glad that we've got these
aligned okay and what's your point here
other than that this is possible the
things that works for small doesn't
necessarily work for large very nice now
why am I not saying this is not purple
boxed because this is now a graphic
because it's graph plot is that correct
graphics yes um okay so coordinate tools
options I don't really understand what
that is given that this thing isn't
offering me coordinate tools why sort of
that the old you know curve plot options
some just showing the difference we
still support them but in no longer
corporate options but I understand I'm
saying the coordinate tools options why
is that um those were the old options
did you see here those are the old
options that are no longer options oh I
see I see I understand okay fair enough
so that's was a way of doing annotation
how what is the modern version of this
label connotation happily so if I do
this with a labeled wrapper that's the
modern version much better okay okay so
there's a plot theme which you're not
yet supporting in the in the
autocompletes
correct but that's just because the
documentation needs to be yeah
dear futurist what does this mean it's
just a name for that theme but why is
that why that toothy how are we getting
to that before so it was first my
mistake the name of the plot team is
classic on the classic diagram so that's
the old name and this is yes okay but
why is when a classic diagram before in
the old graph plot how did you get to
that thing how did you get to the
labeled thing you do vertex vertex
labeling goes to true okay but why are
we calling it diagram why don't we just
calling it like classic labeled if we're
calling it anything I mean because I
mean why wouldn't this just be this with
vertex labeling arrow automatic why
didn't that work did you answer my
question yes probably something you have
to fix but yeah it will work that's just
a bug so something is wrong there yes
uh okay so a question from our live
stream if self-loop style is no longer
an option do we still have a way to
control the size of selfloops not 20
hopefully soon ouch okay
why did we remove the self loop style
option cuz its first is Nauti style two
is you know is a parameter a factor on
essentially it's kind of hard to control
essentially it was just me to be city of
the set of point around that loop okay
what other functionality are we losing
here I went over this too quickly
so essentially you can't duplicate the
self love salvaging of vertex shape
function essentially you just have to
quite the way shape function how is it a
grotesque is it yeah you have to write
some code so it's not that that's not
good so what are we gonna do with the
page about self loop style which is a
documented feature right so currently
the plan is that currently if you put
self loop style we still return you this
simple cough block so you oh I see I see
so if self loop style is included it
goes back to the old graph plot exactly
until we gonna generate a message of
some kind or not no probably not
no okay well what other things like that
what other incompatibilities like that
are they're just self will Stalin with
th style those are the two wants hmm
okay and so that will go back to the old
okay but so you're going to get what are
you planning to do well I mean this
doesn't look totally stupid here if I
might say so I mean maybe it should have
been called self-loop rendering but I
think we intended self-loop style to
have string names to be able to draw
them in you know in specified styles I'm
not thrilled that this is just silently
going away I mean what what is the plan
here I mean he's not going away it's
just that you know even in the new craft
we don't need that because still to me
you know the alternation you don't
actually have to bother about the size
of the self-loop so you're telling me if
I were to put a self-loop in here that I
would be happy as a clam about what it
does that is nice I'm happy I mean is it
are you telling me here if I were to
fall for sure there's a limit right I
mean it's you
so let me let me just for the hell of it
let me just add in here um just to be
mean okay I'm gonna add in here Oh
actually let me just go ahead and
flatten
that's rather attractive
let me Mina not bad I mean you know
that's unfortunate but that seems very
hard to detect um so this is by default
not a directed graph um yes you have to
does does the same default in half Lotus
before you have to put directed edge
goes to true the default is false but is
that an option we're continuing with yes
oops what just happened there why did it
change sighs well it's it's not bad this
is really not bad and so your argument
is I just don't need the UM that those
options are not so important why did
that why did that not have a smooth edge
yeah so partly you need to move to more
assignment therefore the beautiful edges
but what is it normally is it a b-spline
or is it something else yes it B spline
I'm surprising that a B spline would
have looked like that or maybe we just
we thought has lines choice when do this
example
um yes um but this was really looking
quite good
in my opinion all right so so the basic
plan for right now is if you have a
self-loop option it will revert to the
old graph plots with the idea that there
will be some investigation of a new of
new self loops yes
correct yes okay so here to me I don't
understand why you don't call this like
classic labeled I just don't think
diagram you know that's a whole nother
idea oh well okay
at least you admitted to that right
there so what is the saying here so in
it that's doing this but that's not
reverting to the old graph plot that's
just doing
that's ignoring those options right what
I mean that's the 2d build I mean we
made a change lately where we have to
you know if you put the old options we
you know we used old are you sure that's
the right thing to do because honestly
the new stuff really looks quite good
I mean maybe what you should do is
somebody on our live stream is asking
what is the limit on the number of live
street on the number of a self-loop sort
of vertex okay let's find out I would
say the limit is very large I don't
think there's anything disastrous
happening right it's just gonna keep
doing that isn't it yes um why is it
necessary to supply the directed edges
option when the graph definition already
uses directed edges yeah well for graph
so that is an interesting question
whether we should change that I I mean
that would be a scary thing to change
and I kind of think we shouldn't change
it because what's being you know the
point there is if this was other what's
this I mean how do we do this now this
thing here the vertex rendering function
that would be how do we how do we
achieve this this functionality now we
to the dickship falls on on the pretty
much the same option but we just why did
we change I mean Scott in this case what
we have is graph plot does
and graph why is that different why is
that because the two different curve and
we we picked orientation we pick a
different layout because this is a
directed graph we use a layer takeoff to
show the structure we should be picking
I see so but if I were to replace in
here if I were to replace rule with
two-way rule Oh beautiful
okay but the issue here is the
assumption of whether it is a directed
graph or not is different between graph
plot and graph that is a bit unfortunate
I mean if you stick if you don't use
rules then you know if you just know
it's you I understand OSU and I assume
that graph plot is fine and I abused I
mean I viewed rule as sort of a it's a
courtesy issue to allow rule the fully
correct thing is edges you know
undirected edge directed edge right can
I see how you do this in the modern
world okay what is the what is the way
to do that um they take ship function
mm-hmm I'm probably copy the same shape
function because oh no do we have a
function that allows you to put the
labels in circles yes okay my second
question is why is that turning red and
that's probably just is that just
documentation not addition okay all
right fine but this is a nice style and
it would be really good to be able to
have that style be easy to get to right
if we can name it but do we have that
yet I mean do we have a collection of
vertex shape function named retic shape
functions
yes or a vertex style or something we
have a set of text shape function but
they don't include by default labeling
but you can put labels you can place you
know label Center center but I think we
should do that I mean we should have
some I would suggest having some that
include labeling I think it sounds more
like a theme because it combines multi
elections you're right you're right
so do we have themes for these yet um
yes you have I mean you have the
stand-up lot teams plus two specific
teams what what specific ones do we have
by the way that autocomplete is less
than wonderful I think I think we should
customize that autocomplete for graphs
especially if there are some additional
themes yes I think we do that already
for class we do the same for cough blood
okay so you're saying there yes very
nice so where is the wet where are the
special ones so if you you know extend
that menu I think we have classic white
the last tool I think if this is
important or whatever large graph is is
important is it important
yes when you reach the threshold off a
you know thousand vertices and edges
then we change you know we instead of
throwing you know circle if you know you
switch to point out if you change the
color on search why do we change the
color when the graph gets big because we
did different colors almost invisible
let's look at that for a second I don't
understand why we go from blue to orange
it just seems that seems crazy to me and
in the naively okay so if I say
something like this okay I'm still blue
how do I go I mean I'm fine being blue
here specifying your plot theme
okay but maybe there's a choice to go to
a different color okay that makes sense
to me I sorry I thought I thought you
meant we were default lis going oh no -
I see where the point is to have more
contrast between the edges and the
vertices yes still that makes perfect
sense um but I think you should put it
higher up in the autocomplete menu okay
we have something from the livestream
here somebody with a piece of code let's
run it um that's perfectly nice well
that's actually a pretty civilized piece
of code that seems to work quite nicely
yeah good I mean I hope that's
documented properly it is good okay
let's move on then alright was there
something that we still it was
unconcluded here I mean there's the self
loop style thing whether - may I make
the suggestion that if it sets a self
what we could do an alternative to what
you're doing right now is generate a
message and say use use plot theme arrow
classic if you want the old behavior and
expect that we are largely duplicating
those options it's okay rather than
automatically revert to the old behavior
what do you think Roger
I agree video I think we need to salute
I don't want to know I want to just
softly nudge them forward and mm-hmm
and then we can get more once we have it
running for a version or two we can can
be my local fine okay onward we are
rewriting a state tax law or something
it was properly inheritance that's mind
sorry okay what are we doing here so
this has to do with
so this one that use is inherited for
the vertex coordinates right okay you
can specify that you shouldn't inherit
them well now what are we doing what
what did it do before it wouldn't it did
never inherit him it would regenerate
are you sure this is the right default I
really am not convinced this as the
right default at all I think this is
great behavior I would really like to
see this being the default and then this
being something you can set I just think
this case is a rare case where it
actually looks reason you know we have a
lot of this is one where we have a lot
of reports where people want this
behavior really yes so that was one TV
you know for the last five year that was
one of the key complaint where people
want you know that we preserve those
property as well as a layout can we
really change this at this point I mean
ah isn't there a lot of stuff where
where I mean preserving the layout I
understand but that is the layout well
no no no preserve okay if I say in here
for example let's say I say graph um
and I say um you know vertex labeling
goes to automatic for example six levels
okay fine that's very an elegant why did
it why did it over print why does it or
no to go outside yeah we are working on
that that's actually project ready you
know to fix the labeling
I don't know I'd be curious since we
obviously have some users of our graph
functionality on the live stream I'd be
interested in people's opinion there
about some about whether this is a good
default I'm concerned don't you get into
stupid situations in some cases well
that's why we went manually for some by
function to actually picked you no no I
understand but specifically for this for
sub graphs but what what's defined
stupid I don't know now I mean what is
that a wise automatic inherited I would
have thought vertex coordinates to
automatic would reset the vertex
coordinates so this is you well I mean
the default value if you do option of
sub graph the default value of x
coordinate is automatic so we define
automatically what to pick so we pick
that we are going to do the inheritance
we can't reach it back off to none so if
you say no then we don't innovate the
Vettes coordinate you know we have an
interesting comment from our live stream
here which I will paste into our current
notebook so the point made was that if
you have edge weights it's obviously a
good idea to to inherit them but this is
a good point yes but I mean it's that's
a good point on be aware of that I mean
and that's why we make the decision as
even the default curve when we hit a
certain threshold you make a Y decision
to compute a Vettes coordinate or not
because that's an expensive thing yeah
but you have to know no but well hold on
a second you have to compute the vertex
coordinates if you're going to pull them
out
over to the to the subgraph you have to
have computed them beforehand for the
whole graph so even if the sub graph is
just three elements if the original
graph had a million elements you have to
compute the layout before you can find
the elements but find those three
elements yes
seems like a very bad idea no that was
actually one of the key issues we
haven't actually done those property for
the last five years so we needed to
check which function you D coastally on
what why isn't this very costly to move
I mean you know I I have to say I think
the default for vertex coordinates
should be none or what I think the
setting for automatic should be which is
recompute them I think in heritage
should be a thing you have to set I just
don't think people expect this this is
this this denies graph theory basically
this is saying it matters what the
layout of the of the vertices is which
is just not what graph theory is about I
mean what are you going to do when you
do a graft union you're not gonna do
this I think this is a mistake I think
the default should be what it has been
which is you know recompute the
coordinates then and but I think this is
very useful what you have here of being
able to inherit the coordinates so we're
just arguing about sub graph we're
arguing about sub graph we're arguing
about the default for vertex coordinates
for sub graph and I strongly think that
it should be in automatic which should
mean recompute them okay okay that's
what I think so how many what other ones
I mean edge weights obviously we want to
move over that would be crazy not to
move the edge weights to the sub graph
but I think anything that is a you know
attached to the graph so to speak like
edge weights makes sense anything that
is a kind of a you know a metal layer
like the embedding in space should not
be moved over
that's my everything is everything apart
from the pure connectivity is meta no
but well okay styles shapes everything
um maybe that's just the embedding that
I'm making a fuss about you're right we
do want to move over if one of those
vertices was colored red we want to move
that over in subgraph the embedding is
slightly tricky because somebody can
specify the vertex coordinate explicitly
in the polygon sorry
in the in the curve right so now to
matic what we do we just disregard them
and also in the future we are planning
to do the constraint layout right where
somebody give partial theta x coordinate
and then we is that still no I thought
that was gone now is that I mean the
base code for Spring electrical is there
but is more complicated actually we have
to do that for all the layout all these
many layout okay so wait a minute the
point that you're making which I don't
disagree with it is if somebody
explicitly set the coordinates then I
you know then I'm much more partial to
moving them over to inheriting them the
case that I don't like is the case where
the coordinates were found automatically
okay but is that is that doable is there
a way to do that to you know to move
over only the ones that were set
explicitly or do you not know which ones
were set explicitly we know that's what
I think the default should be and and
perhaps what that should be so automatic
then should mean move over ones that
were set explicitly don't move over the
ones that were were not and I guess none
although I think it's a little odd means
um kind of move over move over none of
them and inherited moons move over all
of them make sense yes okay let's take a
look at some of these other okay so
let's
all right so wait a minute the the
inherited yeah I get it
but now okay so you understand what I'm
claiming about automatic automatic would
typically mean you know inherit if it
was Auto generate if it was given by the
user don't inherit if it was Auto
generated yes but now let's look at some
of these other properties um so you're
saying okay so if I look at the other
properties that can exist in a graph
what should I understand about what gets
um what gets sort of what annotations
get moved over and what happens in like
a graph Union right so do an aerial
addition those are the only one where I
mean you have to make it a choice yep so
for cough Union we twenty we just
decided to um so that's the you know not
it is joined Union right so for the de
jure Union that's obvious we carry
everything because that judgment for the
Union we pick the first cuff which is
similar to what we do in show with
multiple plots and things right yes
it's not the most wonderful thing to
pick okay so hold on a second in a graph
Union okay first question is how do you
real able the vertices in a graph Union
am I confused I mean if I take this
graph and I say a graph Union of that
graph comma that graph oh boy so I know
what happened so that is two union graph
Union and Virginia so this Union
essentially does the union of the
vertices right so since okay so because
I had those vertex label names you're
saying I got this so if I were to do for
exam
here I would say complete graph of eight
or something okay and then I was to put
that in there you're telling me I would
just get a complete graph of eight
elements because that thing there
already exists that is really confusing
so if I would but if I were to real Abel
that how do I real Abel the vertices
here there a good way to do that so a
good way to relive all the vertices
let's see three index do we have that I
think that takes place and then you just
change one okay so okay it's nice that
it didn't lose the idea that it was
keeping um vertex labeling I know maybe
that wasn't profound that it didn't lose
that idea okay so let's try this guy
okay
wait a minute what the heck is that
doing now I'm even more confused what
did that just do because essentially now
you have to I mean the first half all
the way to start at you know above ten
and order one at eight so destroying
what how did it managed to have a vertex
in the middle there what's going on so
wait a minute you skipped zero in your
replace in your table for replace vertex
replace there isn't a zero there isn't a
zero okay let's let's get labeling here
let's let's do in this case here how do
I so the other thing that happened is it
lost the labeling of that first graph
well first of all I think it's just the
change of the layout didn't preserve the
layout because two differently are
complete refused a sequel embedding
layout since the graph are no longer
sighs okay all right so let's take a
look at what it did here vertex labels
are automatic okay you're right so okay
so that but but okay so you're saying
that when I do graph Union it matters
it's doing it based on the actual labels
of the vertices yeah under names we call
the name labels is something else yeah
okay okay okay right I get it
okay so the question is now if one of
these graphs was so why is there a
problem here unless unless if the thing
attaches okay so here if I go I goes to
I plus four for example here um and then
I put that guy in then I will have
something where I've got a tangled web
right okay so now the issue is so now
I'm actually confused here because that
had vertex labeling and that didn't and
yet this thing didn't end up with vertex
labeling in the end that confuses me
yeah for the cartoonion we have and
since you know we are still deciding we
haven't really fully implemented to do
fine but what should we do I mean
arguably what nurse should we do because
if we've got two nodes I mean this is a
gun a calculus of annotations problem
because we could have two eight nodes
and one of them is blue in the first
graph and it's green and the second
graph what should we do well I think
what we don't want to do right now but
what we could do eventually if it this
becomes a real issue is to design a
resolving function something that that
you have to supply as a user yeah well
it's it's analog analogous to a key
collision function right and Association
yes I do think that that's a sensible
thing to do eventually but I kind of
don't want to go there now unless I
agree not ready we're not ready for that
right now
as we think about graph replacements and
things as we think about things that
necessarily rename you know like a graph
replacement is going to be adding
vertices to a graph with random numbers
in them and for example do we have a way
to Rican analyze the labels of a graph
yes
what's it called what is it yeah so that
means an Abba static properties to the
annotation framework where the mutation
value on such canonical graph that's
really cool okay so for example if I did
this one well that one doesn't have any
weird vertices okay so canonical graph
just means we re label so if I took that
graph well here if I say if I say
canonical graph on this and this is now
going to be another question about about
um so canonical graph of that okay it
lost the vertices vertex labels why but
just specify that you want them no but I
had them here so why didn't I have them
here how I see the inheritance wise yes
I mean this may be explicit go ahead it
may be that the argument is canonical
Josh just rewrote those labels but the
question is what was what happened here
at vertex labeling our automatic was its
specific vertex labeling when this is
very confusing I mean the case of
canonical graph is different and I think
we haven't yet included it there because
canonical graph gives you a cough which
is canonical so if you have to cough
each isomorphic you get the same
canonical cough right yes and you hope
that if we start when traduz inheritance
of labeled a automatically that means
somebody will give you to graph which is
a morphic but you'll return two
different results oh you're right you're
right chops that's super confusing yeah
I understand but so so one question
would be partial canonicalization like
for example renumber in vertices but not
changing their properties
because that seems useful to me right so
one idea was like for the graph seen on
the actually if I think we actually do
that so the option is property right or
what we were going to call our notations
he set up to none so that means we don't
see if a user wanted then he was set up
that property or the inheritance no
option but when I in canonical God no I
was talking I think we haven't yet don't
African don't I'll cough you are done
that for cash Union so if you do option
of graph Union we see that the property
said to mom wait a minute so that would
be the future in in the in the options
version of annotations it's called
annotations and it's an option correct
position horse yes but why on earth of
these not in alphabetical order
okay forget by the way by the way I'm
just surprised and andraia I think is on
this call could you could you make sure
that that um the testing folk check that
I mean something we used to check years
ago that the default options are enough
vertical order I have no idea why how
that ever got not to happen but no case
um our user on the live stream is
pointing out that index graph apparel
deaths when I was him that's what I was
looking for it's very good that we have
um thank you so ok so if I take that and
I say index graph of that now at now
drum roll it's gonna lose the the labels
okay so what can be done about this what
should be done about this so if those
labels were explicitly given right then
it should lose them presumably
right but if those labels you get what
I'm saying I mean but those labels being
automatic in other words if what this
had in it was vertex labeling but I bet
it does have that if I say options of
that oh well it doesn't give vertex why
doesn't he kill for text labels Oh
automatic oh because that's the actual
things in the graph and so confused here
so I claim that vertex labels are
automatic should be inherited here see
what I'm saying yes do you agree with me
yes okay so so again let's go through it
again if the setting is automatic well
okay so if vertex labels in the index
graph okay if I said vertex labels arrow
inherited in the index graph what would
it do so if the graph have a vertex
label set I mean in a way that you will
just essentially get what is originally
from the graph so if it's automatic you
will probably pick the name so that mean
if somebody generate a graph where the
label are you know some random string or
image when you are playing Dex calf they
will deliver will change to numbers yeah
that's right I think right but if it
purely if we say vertex labels are
inherited here I love this bug whatever
the heck is I wonder what that says um
okay let's not even worry about that but
but but you agree that this should come
out that should do something yes or no
yes okay all right fine
okay all right so question so the NRA
functions I mean that this clearly some
more of this to figure out I mean is
there a big table of what you've
actually done in terms of inheritance
for these things yes you have the least
of so far 25 functions could you send me
that list could we could we take a quick
look at that list livestream is pointing
out that it's weird that they were not
inherited because they say usually they
are well that wasn't inherited now so
maybe it previously was inherited do you
know differently sure well you're wrong
look inherited it says that the vertex
but wait a minute
where text labels automatic yes somehow
that moved over the options to that
graph and then in the new case you
didn't move over the options to the
graph no but um yes because white
correct because before we were dream
pretty much that all in place so he was
keeping everything from the original
cough which is in personal live stream
points had in discovers one of the few
functions that did preserve properties
in previous versions but now it doesn't
but but but we agree it should in this
case right yes it's not just yet
implemented okay fine all right let's go
let's go on and look at the other things
here I send you the least okay great
okay so what are we looking at here so
let's make this a little bigger
okay so these are all the functions so
for example index or index graph is
there a graph power that's a horrifying
case find spanning tree well that one
surely you want to keep edge weights and
stuff like that when you find the
spanning tree right because he's a
subclass yes okay but the fact that it
doesn't have a check mark just is means
what yes
oh you have an update this I think by
the time you are not releasing it but
it's party implemented a beauty so okay
okay okay so let's just take a look at
these what does boolean graph - it's
Union intersection everything you takes
a boolean function oh wow any boolean
cloggin and graphs yes that's cool
that's interesting so that Roger you're
returning to your roots this is binary
relations somehow meats graphs inside
yes yes okay
the it's interesting is it useful tune
and graphs together don't know okay
NAND in particularly the I'm sure there
is
you know NAND is a useful relation so
it's allocating and graphs you know
represent relation so sure okay
what about let's see when you have
planar graph what is simple graph form
what's play note what about planar graph
does that keep what does so clearly if
you say planar graph is gonna blow away
any um well go ahead what we means
because sometimes you could say planar
graph and you could have given vertex
coordinates which are incompatible with
it being a planar graph yes
so what happens in that case um I think
you if I mean the card needs first to be
play now right otherwise you would fail
is he playing Julia cost octo - no - you
see fair enough right but but country's
a planar graph of a non planar I mean if
I say can't you say planar graph to
force the planar graph embedding city to
force no no he says force it but you
can't if it's not planar you can't force
it to well no no I understand that but I
know but listen what I mean is
connectivity wise the graph is planar
but embedding wise the graph was forced
to be non planar okay what I'm saying in
other words it's rezard non planar way
but it is by connectivity it is planar
right so then what happens with respect
to inheritance during every test is
independent independent of the layout
right so we know the inherit but the
inheritance of vertex coordinates is
absolutely to do a layout also we have a
precedence in no into the commercial
side so vertex coordinate take
precedence over decaf layout so if you
specify the vertex coordinate it over
wider calf layout x coordinate are
automatic then we use the layout or the
calf layout option to determine how to
photograph okay okay all right well okay
so let's just keep going on this there
was a common Latin neighborhood graph so
neighborhood graph I would assume
inherits everything except but it
shouldn't inherit the coordinates right
in the same way that sub graph should
inherit the coordinates by default I
think
opinions are split around these things
yes you know because we have a bunch of
bug reports that want them inherited
well I want the possibility of them
being inherited or some people always
expecting you know when you do a graph
layout on the neighborhood just you know
to visually actually see that nib or
does the only way you can identify look
neighborhood graph I accept with the
sufficiency issue which seems rather
horrifying neighborhood graph I can see
more of an argument for that sub graph I
really don't see the argument what other
cases will have the possibility in both
were just discussing defaults right yeah
we're discussing the default okay and so
the question is should neighborhood
graph I mean I would argue perhaps that
the efficiency argument would wait you
know would tip it over
so does neighborhood graph preserve the
embedding right now do you mean in the
x3 no okay so I I don't think it should
going I don't think it should by default
I think you should set it I just think
you know it denies the graph enos of a
graph to you know to by defaults move
over the subheading that's we have a
sliding scale of uses there's a lot of
people that use graphs main difference I
think in the board coffee actually
preserve it really the user on a live
stream was indicating remember we did
that little experiment that in some
phones somewhere we've behaved that I
mean we thought that we should preserve
it we kept it but at that time we didn't
have this the tooling to do it more
generally for this inheritance if if we
put it in neighborhood golf right now
leave it leave the default the way it is
right now yep
um oh boy we have a bunch of comments on
our livestream all sorts of things
comment about undirected graph how do we
preserve edge weights if two reciprocal
edges are merged into one that's a good
question I mean how do you combine the
edge weights if you have a goes to B has
an edge weight and B goes to a has an
edge weight what do we do I mean
obviously it needs a combiner function
for that case this but what is it that
will cause those two edges to be
combined what function causes those to
be combined
is it undirected graph or what but
undirected graph will take those two
edges and smoosh them into one but does
it do the right thing with the edge
weights it's that way by default so you
know some of those phones on which are
pure you know topological based on this
the structure of the curve you know
every time we we just drop those
properties they seem I play for simple
car thief having beautiful edges and you
call simple graph how you going to
preserve those property right the
labeled weights on my point of view
depend on the use you know the proper
chap specific the user property of a
general property the basis to turn them
off and then the user precise that I
mean no no I understand but the point
being made is if you say make an
undirected graph out of a directed graph
with edge weights there is an argument
that there should be a combiner function
in the undirected graph that says what
to do with the edge weights yes or in
general what to do with you know if
they're colored edges and things so
obviously we're not getting that for
1200 but that seems that you agree that
that's a reasonable suggestion yes the
simple Anjum okay next comment here um
same question was simple graph yeah okay
that was what you just heard sometimes
you do need to preserve layout of sub
graphs we agree and that's why there's
an option being proposed to make that
possible for example what about
what about cities well you know the
point is that as we just said the
default if you gave the coordinates
explicitly then they would be preserved
it's only if the graph was automatically
laid out at the beginning which wouldn't
be the case for cities so I think
there's a really strong case in both
okay and if the reports that we've seen
are mostly that they want it because
they they didn't have it so obviously
they didn't report that it was you know
it was it was correct yeah right um
right the uh I think um right so a
comment also being made here any
Geograph by the way we haven't you know
we intend to have a function called
Geograph in the future that gets road
networks and all kinds of things like
that but we don't have that yet and
clearly in that case okay so let's talk
about that case for a second all right
imagine that okay so a geographer yeah
yeah that will work correctly with our
defaults a Geograph would have
explicitly set vertex coordinates right
and so then then the defaults that we
are proposing here would be correct um
okay so they're saying more messages
below I'd like to see the messages so
the comments again in eleven three
neighborhood graph does preserve a
vertex coordinates that was yeah right
so that this is this is the point I
think you're making on the live stream
before is that you know there's an
efficiency hit for doing that and you
know this is kind of a complicated issue
right is neighborhood graph again again
okay
first comment we all agree that if you
explicitly set the coordinates in your
graph then preserve them the argument is
about if you didn't explicitly accept
the coordinates what happens um the um
you know what happens to you know what
what happens does it does it take the
automatically generated coordinates or
not
okay other more of these are
automatically generated coordinates are
sometimes very carefully chosen like we
have custom layouts that circles and
bipartite know that they're not just
sort of spring electrical I understand
you're making the argument that they are
the finest coordinates and they should
be preserved at all costs
no I'm just saying that some of them you
know when you get the complete graph it
looks like it would you expect the
complete graph to look like that's not
by accident and it's not it's really not
spring electrical that did that no I
realize that but I mean your point is I
think I correctly represented your point
you're saying these coordinates could
have taken a lot of trouble to make yes
and so okay so that that raises another
possibility okay
oh boy that's another case right because
what you're describing is what if you
used a not hey I don't believe in this
case okay so what what happens okay take
two graphs right okay so I'm assuming
that the you know the the type of
embedding the embedding generator
whatever it is the graph layout option
that I'm assuming that that is okay what
happens to the inheritance of that so in
other words let's say you said I want a
layered layout okay and then you change
the graph in some way does the newly
produced graph maybe it's a subgroup
well subgraph I think where is off that
we're not well obviously shouldn't be
okay question let's say an original
graph is a layered layout then you take
a sub graph is the sub graph also
layered layout or not to go what I'm
asking
you know a choice I think it is already
now because it it just have waited the
general automation work it would pick a
layer layout anyway what you just
carried that property okay but okay but
so then is it the property that's
carried or is it affected its you know
well it might be a map for graph
theoretic reasons it might be some right
that's what I'm thinking
layered before then it's gonna sub
graphs gonna preserve that property no I
understand but so I can blow that away
let me do a graph power or something
like that I don't know a fan but I would
guess I can easily blow away whatever
whatever you give me there I can blow it
away by doing something different sure
right so then the question is does it
then sort of you know inherit through
the layering layout or not I mean that's
a different case that's a of the the
case that you already discussed with
with explicit coordinates that's one
thing but let's say you set I it is not
clear to me what it should do right in
other words so when we went with this
this whole thing of updating what we
find out that you know it was you know
per function that was wanting and you
know it's hard to have a you know a
general policy the one example is the
spamming tree right mmm somebody gives
you a graphically layout right whatever
layout thing electrical and is farming
tree what do you want to generate
usually while somebody will expect is to
see something which have a structure of
III yes fair enough yes you could also
expect it to be you know like the
original graph which might not look like
a tree at all that's exactly where
vertex coordinates are inherited versus
vertex coordinates you know in other
words if if the thing was yeah I think I
think what we're talking about the
default there is correct but I think
this is a new case which is you've
specified a type of layout method should
you inherit that and you're arguing that
in a few specific cases I mean like the
layering property sure you can inherit
that but circular
embeddings or something who knows
whether you should inherit that I tend
to think you probably shouldn't inherit
the the the layout by default the layout
type by default I'm not sure I don't
know do you think its function dependent
yeah I think it's functional dependence
well so so perhaps we should see in this
picture you know there should be a
bigger table that indicates which also
might be good for documentation
somewhere but that indicates what is
preserved in which function you must
know that right yes okay oh no
livestream is pointed out that combining
edge weights should be an option edge
weight combiner yes I agree I mean
that's presumably what you have in mind
something like that for the case of
going from a directed to an undirected
graph for instance all right let's try
to get to the end of the agenda maybe
we'll come back to this I mean this is
this is clearly a very complicated issue
what should be and it will be good to
try do you have that that big table of
everything not City no one yeah build
one and let's let's see it um I think I
think it'd be worth doing another
iteration on this because I think it's
it's some you know the more we can get
these defaults right first time the
better off we are
um okay let's keep going here small
additions um yeah and also pointed out
that we need a vertex property combiner
for vertex contract agreed um okay small
additions entity integration graph
entities oh that's nice so in other
words if I say um what's an example of a
graph I don't know um Peterson graph
even right spelling yes so if I say what
would I say if I say something like
graph power I don't know what I'm doing
here but let's say that comma to just do
half we have to finish to full
integration integration
for some of the function I see I see
okay so that that's if I just do that
help
okay fine beautiful okay um button now
if I take that what does this lovely
okay
enter do it okay gravity embedding you
requested layout what is that - just
open it the examples blue what does that
do where's the gravity well it is where
it was sorry I don't sound gone well I
say essentially it computer cough Center
so we find the if I take center and then
we apply the spring electrical which
that's why I see cavity
I'm baiting wait wait wait wait where's
the gravity are we talking gravity as in
attraction to a center of mass of some
kind of water yes yes assistant of mass
so we find computer center of mass in
this case a coffe Center something close
and then we have a taxi force attached
with me that while the vertices where
the edges curved just to make it look
nice
so that was coming from me a paper if
you do remember Bob okay so hold on if I
take this thing and I say let's do this
splob okay all right so then I go here
let me let me get rid of all this stuff
and just just I just wanna see the
default okay all right and now now what
you're saying is if I just do G I could
just do G itself so I I'm fairly
confused here about what's happening
no it's just one new layout is not it a
fully art is just but I still want to
know what what do that what does the
curviness mean I mean that seems like an
independent thing whether it's curved
and and then I don't understand what
cause I mean like like that that edge
seems like it just could be a straight
edge yes I mean layout is just look
white what looked nice he seems like
when that curves it look nice okay fine
but we could we we could in spring
electrical we can have curves as well
sure yes is it worth having a curved
spring electrical noise just it ship
phan Strom goes to b-spline it seems to
me that the name gravity embedding is
rather generic for this and it would
seem to me more likely that a name like
that would mean something related to
falling down to the ground rather than
some kind of in orbit gravity type thing
is there another name we could come up
with for this it just seems like it's
very hard to guess what this would do I
mean they're all quite hard to guess
okay let me give you my version I
continued names Houston Aero software is
even worse as they used like the names
of people unless you unless you have
that and a joke list no I understand but
I would have thought gravity embedding
would be more like make a mobile out of
this thing with pieces of wire and have
it hang down Oh which I think would be a
reasonable embedding I mean there
clearly is an embedding that is imagine
these things are you know beams members
of some kind and you know hang it from
somewhere it's actually close right in
3d that's coffee the same if you specify
the center point let me see if I believe
you
really yeah the center seems to be in
the middle there can i specify what how
would I pick this doesn't look at all
like I mean what I was thinking okay but
but but but it's it's being attracted to
the center right well I'm so confused
but I mean if I pick it up from the sky
here right yes and those beams have a
certain I don't know Young's modulus
whatever I there's more than that
actually but best um I mean this is
quite beautiful looking but I still
don't understand I don't understand it
okay you're claiming that what I'm
saying about picking it up from one
thing is sort of what it's doing is that
right yes if we give a control on do
I've shot that point if you can't
specify that you he does so we
automatically picked the center point
and adding gravitate to that okay but
it's gravity to that point rather than a
next oh yes yes right I mean so what I'm
saying is if there's an ambient gravity
field as opposed to we could do
experiments with another version of this
that says you know gives it a parameter
you specify the acceleration due to
gravity so to speak yeah but light I
mean all right all of these things
require a bit of experimentation all
right I agree there's a pretty nice
layout this is interesting all right if
you think gravity layout is you know
gravity embedding is good enough as a
description okay with me it troubles me
a bit as you say it's obscure to know
what these are um
okay and that large seam something's
pointing out shouldn't edge curvature
help visually distinguish close parallel
edges they should be a felon have
opposite curvature is that what's
happening here no we can't do that yet
really but in the future we might expect
that a multigraph would would get things
that bulge out and I mean it already
tells bulge doesn't it yes yes that's
not in this not in this embedding I mean
that's not that's not the nature whoops
I mean so you're talking about um no
that's the point I can't see that you
will happen yeah for that yes right but
in in the case of this gravity embedding
um they've chose to flip it around but
nothing more with its grid Green
embedding or anything that's because I
autocomplete it wrong right because who
knows what that's doing okay so that's
just horrifying and we don't know what's
happening there but you know we can't
expect every embedding to do well in
every situation um okay edge wait well
it's just you know user I've been
requesting that it you know we have a
with that cough but you don't know if
it's a vertex or the edge which have the
weight so they need the function if you
function to but I mean it's a truly
trivial thing Stephen but it's sort of
it's kind of more utility programming
utility wise is it useful for for
patterns and things yeah exactly so
you're gonna ask for pattern question
mark edge-weighted graph queue mm-hmm
you know is that exactly utility okay
well a lot of lovely functionality um
clearly this inheritance business is
complicated it would be nice to see the
full thing but a lot of great stuff
and how big can we do how big how big a
graph can we reasonably do for plotting
I mean the reputation we've we've done
with billions of notes really Williams
yeah
so if I say um but then the algorithms
of what the operations you do on them
they vary greatly in complexity some are
very easy some are super hard so did
that actually compute a new graph yes
yes
that was pretty spiffy but now I see
that's not rendering by default
yeah we have a threshold where we stop
the boundary but if I say graph plot
[Music]
okay all right fine so graph plot is
going to always do it yes okay well
wonderful stuff hey thanks to folks on
livestream also very very useful
comments today much appreciated and I
hope you like the new functionality um
and thanks Roger Charles etc and I guess
some torches soon I'm looking forward to
our next dumb
yeah thanks meeting ok ok kids see you
overmuch ok bye